(rhythmic music)
(train horn)
- I feel like that saying if they say,
you can make it in New York,
you can make it anywhere.
I am from Brooklyn, so I
feel like I can do anything.
My name is Carter Clinton, and
I'm a genetic anthropologist
and a National Geographic Explorer.
Presently, one of the major issues
that we find in genomic research,
is the lack of representation
for African Americans.
Genomic research is the
study of all of your genes
at a basic level.
And one of the major goals of this project
was to contribute
information from a historic,
African American population.
Soil has a lot of secrets
that you can't see with the naked eye.
I'm studying 400 year old grave soil
to learn more about the
health and lifestyles
of a historic African American population.
(footsteps)
(oriental music)
So this is the New York
African Burial Ground.
It's now a national monument.
(oriental music)
In 1991, a construction
crew attempted to erect
a federal building at 290 Broadway.
Being one of the taller
buildings in the area,
it was about 30 stories high,
they had to dig 30 feet below.
And around 25 feet
they began to uncover and
unearth human remains.
After they found the human remains,
they went back to the historical maps,
and they realized that
they had just rediscovered
the New York African Burial Ground.
419 were excavated,
and that's out of an
estimated 15,000 individuals,
over 6.6 acres of land.
So here we have
the New York African Burial
Ground Grave Soil Collection,
housed at Howard University.
And each of the samples
represents an individual
who was buried 400 years ago,
and each sample is collected
from a specific body region,
from each of those individuals.
So we each have our own
unique bacterial community,
or signature, if you will, of
bacteria that live within us,
on us, like on our skin, and our gut.
When we die, that bacteria
is the leading force
in how our bodies are decomposed.
So what we're looking at is what survives
after 400 years after a
person has been buried.
So we took the original soil samples,
we sieved it, we collected
those fine particles,
and then we attempted a DNA extraction.
So we did that hundreds of times,
over the span of about six months.
And then one day, we actually got results.
It was the best day ever,
it was the best day ever.
So, even hundreds of years
after a person passes away,
you can see infectious disease bacteria
that may be the result of
what that person died from.
(running water)
(piano playing)
I feel proud.
I feel proud to be an African American
working on what could possibly
be my direct ancestors.
Being an African American
and native New Yorker
at the same time.
It's so much more than just the tangible.
It's the knowledge that you had ancestors
who lived years ago,
that contributed to this greater picture
that you're now a part of.
So we're not just contributing to science,
we're contributing to history.